the devastation in villages in South
kivu is hard to put into words rescue
efforts are ongoing but without proper
equipment to do the job the process is
slow and painful everyone here is doing
what they can to help the government is
having a hard time sending heavy
machinery because the roads have been
cut off the only way to travel now is
buy boats in Lake kivo
we're evaluating the needs we're sending
food and non-food items will take
medical supplies to the area we'll also
relocate those who have been affected
into shelters
Alpha Safari says 12 of his relatives
are dead he's looking for the rest of
his family he's been here for days but
he's also struggling with his basic
needs food shelter and clothes
I'm collecting these bits of wood and
sheets to build a shelter but I have to
find a place to build and this won't be
enough I've only got a sheet of metal
and small pieces of wood that can't even
stand up but I'm going to make do with
that and it's going to be difficult it's
a huge burden there are only a few
usable bits and torn sheets nothing else
of you
half workers say they're running out of
supplies to treat the injured they are
worried about water-borne diseases like
cholera
many people have come to Health Centers
like this one to get medical help
Province another tragedy struck west of
the provincial capital on Tuesday
several people are missing in a
landslide in a mining area in masisi
territory miners hired a loud Rumble
those who could run for safety some did
not make it this is another tragedy that
Congolese are grappling with they are
also dealing with armed groups millions
of people are already displaced in this
region Aid workers say they are
overwhelmed Catherine soy Al Jazeera
Goma Democratic Republic of Congo